are we
live are we are you yawning already
brother oh
yeah definitely already
yaw yes we are
live I got to switch
these yeah see my problem is I made a
video I made a video to uh normally I
wait a little bit but man I passed out
earlier today I was out it was a it was
a rap for me man it was a rap hey you uh
dropped two videos today didn't you
I hope I didn't drop too oh was it hold
on well I saw your Starfield okay maybe
I'm just I'm just thinking about the one
you made yesterday
yeah all right guys so what's going on
you guys welcome to the ad show we talk
about the past present future of gaming
got my co-host with me dirt green what's
going on
dirt what up y'all what
up what up yes uh we what's funny is
people
I guess there's so many people on your
side with this this superhero thing I I
feel like it's going to be like a Goku
thing where they're just giving you a
Spirit Bomb to hit me with like like I'm
just visualizing everyone in the chat
with their hands in the air like giving
you energy like it's very very uhing
well you know I just have my thoughts
about it we'll definitely get into
it when a soldier see you got one right
there when the solders said he's he's
with you and I'm not saying they
shouldn't have a superhero game but it's
the way well like we we'll get into it
yeah because we we got a lot stuff to
talk about too
man you know it's uh it's been a very
eventful week very eventful week you
know um first thing what are we playing
D what you playing here recently oh
man
um right now I uh
playing a little Mortal Kombat one that
story is incredible I'm playing the
story right now I I put down Starfield
for a second but I'm really close to the
end so I think I might just go ahead and
finish the campaign and then go back to
some side miss you know because I've
been playing a lot of side missions
which are extremely
good um what else am I playing I've been
playing you know I've playing 2K you
know I like 2K I'm thinking what else
have I been playing it's something I
can't oh for the Motorsport been playing
that
did you see Star code out sold uh 2K oh
yeah we G talk about
that we G talk about that brother yeah I
did see that so yeah I've been I've been
I've been going back and forth I I'm um
I was trying to finish Starfield before
Alex Allan weight comes out Allan weight
2 because I'm excited for that game I'm
still thinking am I going to get
Spider-Man 2 at
launch because I totally waited to play
Miles Morales like a year later no two
years later no actually three years
later cuz I didn't play Miles Morales
until this year and it was it was good
but it you know it was a Spider-Man game
so I thinking do I want to get this one
at launch I might get it but I'm not
going to
usually I'm probably not g to play it
immediately but you know I I also bought
Assassin's Creed Mirage and I haven't
played that yet but you know so that's
about it bro I need to get back to
Mirage to be honest with you yeah I
played a good amount of it but I need to
get back to it because because uh I have
really been enjoying you like it what I
played yeah I enjoy what I was playing
of it yeah I I do want to get into it
actually I need to get my camera you do
like this I'm s my bad you do like I
gotta get my camera I figured I do like
that no I'll just put it back to this
yeah yeah I I uh I've been
playing uh a couple things oh first
thing I did is I got the skin for
Starfield my on my console oh okay yeah
the oh you got that rail Ry yeah it
actually it's kind of crazy like the
packaging they like this supposed to
come out when uh this I ripped it open
okay this is what it comes
in nice like how does it look on your
console um here I'll send you the I
haven't posted it on Twitter yet because
I was making that video here I'll send
it to you on uh
this is what it looks like on my
phone there you go okay it actually
looks pretty good uh the the biggest
criticism I think I can get for it is I
don't like the fact that
um I don't like how I feel like I have
to put my finger in the hole to turn it
on hold on who physically turns on their
console like that you don't I don't
you're right but sometimes I I do like
when I'm sitting down because my Xbox is
right beside it cuz like this is where
all my gaming happens for the most part
in this facility now I do have like an
HDMI that's like rolled up right here
that I like Wing into the living room
because I there's I could move my Xbox
but I can't stand doing that stuff I
gotta so I just Wing that giant long DMI
into the other
room cuz like my living room is
literally right out this door work right
here oh okay yeah it's it's been it's
been hectic man it's been hectic you
know what's funny we to talk about here
that's Starfield Starfield
H yeah
man let's let's jump into this Halo man
because this feels like and maybe this
just me there but it been it's been
nothing but positive uh Xbox news all
week yeah man I haven't got a chance to
play season five yet I probably try it
tonight man because I'm off work
tomorrow so I definitely try today or
tomorrow yeah it it's definitely a very
solid uh experience you know you know
how I know because my brother is a huge
Halo fan
and
he he's really vibing with what's coming
back
uh for those of you don't know season
five just launched let me just go ahead
and set it up season five launched and
they put infe C
armor in the actual season pass did you
have you got a look been able to look at
those yet no I haven't man I haven't
yeah I didn't know if you like seen any
on Twitter or anything like that uh it's
it's kind of crazy like they have one
one on the head that's like coming out
like this and you know stuff like that
unique stuff like that is what's going
to drive people to buy those season
passes because I I will
admit the stuff they showed in the past
it ain't
is not you know I think you can you know
if you look at I
think the season of reach that was the
first season that would that had good
stuff at the end uh but you know you
can't sell us a a a a game like a battle
pass and at the end have like like knee
pads on it and expect us to to gravitate
towards that like for instance if you go
and look at like fortnite battle passes
like they have some crazy skins at the
end of all their battle passes like they
they they
really incentivize you to to really put
your best foot forward what I like about
this update is they're actually letting
you
get uh 're they're letting you
for rank your battle pass up in custom
games and that
yeah that's big but like most companies
they don't let you do that yeah and I
think the reason they're doing that is
because the biggest thing
keeping this
game
is that it's doing so well is because of
the forge mode and the problem with the
forge mode is you can't
generally reward people for you know you
can't reward people for creating in Halo
infinite when you're kind of like
punishing people for playing on the
maps so I think that's the reason the
reason they did that like what do you
feel about that well you know I think
that's that's that's that's cool man um
you know I don't know much about season
five at all because I haven't tried it
at all um but just to see some of the
like you said the positive news
surrounding it um and from what this a
like the things you were telling me that
it sound dope man um like I say you know
I can't talk about a much cuz I haven't
tried any of that but it sounds good man
yeah so what I like about it is you know
they put AI scripting I did see that
yeah I did see that so you can have you
can make your own fire uh fight modes
now I saw somebody had had a bunch of
those little minions and and and a whole
bunch of people just running at them it
look pretty dope man I did know Noti
that though so the biggest thing that I
want to ask you is like do you think
Microsoft and Xbox and 343 should be
worried about people like farming their
their battle passes and custom
games because that that that's
definitely a genuine thing you you
people could make maps that are
dedicated to leveling that up and then
you have your stuff in like an hour like
all 100 ranks because it because that is
the Wormhole that you do open when you
allow that happen I'm kind of curious
what your opinion I'm I'm sure they
thought about all of the consequences of
of allowing this in custom matches I
mean I I can't see them just doing it
without thinking about what people
people could could potentially do with
with you know like um you know with this
but I think I don't know that's a good
question because I don't know you know
like I said I'm sure they thought about
it what I don't I don't know man you
know that's a good question because I
just don't know what they're going to do
now that oh oh so so chill caros said
it's capped it's capped to how like in
customs how much only so much rank per
day there you go that's the answer right
there at it I feel them on that and
that's a good way of you know balancing
it out here's my thing is I don't even
agree with that it's like just just
unlock that stuff like here's the thing
even if people
do and I guess maybe they're looking
from like a perspective on someone just
maxing out that Rank and just not
playing anymore and I guess that's a
genuine concern for for 343 so that's
probably why they put the cap in but
it's like you know they paid that $10 to
get that stuff so if they want if they
want to you know eat up that that pass
playing custom games like custom
infection and stuff oh well you know
what I'm saying
yeah but I can understand from like a
like an engagement perspective you don't
want people maxing that yeah I mean
because you mentioned it you know like
you just said that
Xbox did they think about you know like
people maxing out their stuff and custom
modes so it then like Cho Carlo said no
there is a rank um so Chio Walker said
the cap is seven 7,800 experience points
per day okay well that makes sense um
yeah yeah that makes sense they should
they should let that
stack you think so I said they should
let it stack like I don't know is
7,800 is that like how is that a level
like I don't know I don't know how much
that is like realistically how many
times you level up with
7,800 yeah that's a good question like
is that if that's if it gets to the
point where it's not even one level then
what's the point you know what I'm
saying like like I understand that to to
a degree but it's just like you got to
reward people for playing on custom maps
and that's 11 levels okay that's that's
fair 11 levels that's fair uh you know
7,800
points so can you get that every day or
is that every week an uh that's the
question like I'm kind of curious like I
I needed I should have did a little bit
more research but uh it it's good man
it's good I I think I think 343 is on
the verge of Reviving Halo now I don't
know if
Microsoft
cares because I'm kind of curious that
the damage is already too great to the
ship that they feel like just building a
new ship like you know obviously I think
there's a realm where they're working on
a new story and they just continue to
add on to Halo infinite and then when
the new story comes over because if you
notice they already separated them they
don't call the multiplayer Halo infinite
anymore if I remember correctly it's
called like Halo PVP or something like
that is it like that has two separate
apps doesn't it oh yeah it yeah well
it's always been two separate apps yeah
see to me they put themselves in a
situation where they can separate them
and there just another campaign that
pops in as a different app oh okay yeah
that makes
sense yeah yeah you know that's a good
question because I always did wonder why
were they separate even at launch in
2021 they were separate multiplayer and
a campaign so okay yeah I think I think
it's good man I think we're we're seeing
the results of one app now Alo Joey
saying it's only one that oh
now that's
crazy okay I think Halo infinite has
bright future I just I'm kind of curious
in terms
of in term well someone said ad already
forgot what they what they're saying on
uh on Halo what Phil said on Halo to be
honest with you guys I don't really I
don't necessarily believe half the stuff
that these Executives be saying because
like their their thought process and
stuff that's going on can change from
just depending on what type of you know
something that Phil can say now and the
way business works on an executive level
could change drastically between now and
a couple months from now that's why you
know you had issues with people saying
um what I'm looking for you had issues
with people like Jim Ryan changing his
philosophy multiple times because you
know at that time that's probably what
their philosophy was right but it
changed so you know I'm I'm not saying
like Phil Spencer's lying or anything
like that I'm just saying that sometimes
when these executives are
talking you got to read between the
lines you know uh for the most part I
would say you know three four3 is in a
better situation than they were six
months ago but I don't think they're out
of uh you know well I don't want to say
trouble because I feel like that's
that's a little bit too that's a strong
statement trouble yeah um I would say
they're not out of the W they're not out
of the woods yet you know they they they
they're not going hungry they learned
how to survive but you know they they
they need to get out of the woods now
they need to survive I mean I do think
they're in a much better position cuz
you could you mention it you know like
when you started this conversation
there's a lot of positive feedback Sur
Ron Halo season five and that wasn't
always the case the game start off very
positive very polished and then
somewhere in between people started to
complain about the lack of content
because it because the game play was
never an issue the game play was never
an issue the campaign was solid but it
seemed like to me in between the launch
and like now
there was this hate campaign on Halo
infinite but they did have some issues
obviously because they made some
management changes um but but like I
said you saying that there's positive
feedback right now surrounding Halo
infinite I think that's a positive sign
and that shows that they are headed in
the right direction you can you know I
agree I mean but you can't say they're
officially out out of the the woods or
whatever but they're definitely headed
in the right direction yeah
they know what's going on man Microsoft
they aird drop that how to survive in
the wilderness book like they they
reading that okay this is how we make a
fire like they playing Minecraft in real
life right now yeah and uh you know I I
I really like seeing that they've turned
it around because you know there is a
time where I didn't know I didn't know
like but it does look like it's a little
bit more man it does look more probable
that they can actually turn this around
all right so
let's let's talk about Starfield this is
this is going to be a pretty oh like
just let you know that that J D by block
was not the real Jay it was a fake oh
yeah these guys have been going to every
Xbox podcast they make a fake jayd dub a
fake Dreamcast guy MBG you know all of
the PlayStation guys and they you know
then I check it it's it's not really
them so yeah they they they they doing
tooo much you know it's just like to me
you guys have SP man about the drop why
are they going so it's like it's like
it's like Cog not Cog it's like kitm did
say like
you you have the Metacritic of Spiderman
that you could talk about but for some
reason they're still talking about it
yeah some dud some dudes came here say
asbo has no games what the fake J dub
said that come on chill out fam yeah and
it's just like you guys got other things
to do one would think one would hope you
guys got other places you could be you
know uh games getting canceled on
Playstation over and over again factions
on
Ice Studio heads
rolling uh but you know you guys over
here talking to us so it's like I said
in that in that tweet if you'd spend
more time focusing on your
platform instead of hating on me to play
because I play on mine maybe your
platform would be in a better
situation well about your like you
always say worry about your own house
yeah because your house is on fire the
foundation's falling apart yeah like you
you you you sit in there you you know
those beans where they're blowing on the
fire it's just getting worse yeah like
your house is literally on
fire go put that out before you come
back here don't send for you unless I
sin for you I'm gonna quote keing on
here because you are the reason that
that situation is because it's like
no wonder the PlayStation keep doing
stuff they keep doing they never get
punished for it they they they never get
backlashes for it now I can understand
to some degree you know Xbox people be
letting Microsoft get away with certain
things but we do call Xbox out a
lot for the most part Xbox consumers and
not consumers Xbox content creators
we're making content about Xbox
sure you know there's people and you you
you you you talk about PlayStation a
little bit but it's you never let it be
the the the highlight of the
conversation oh I talk about PlayStation
Fanboys more than anything yeah but but
what my point is you actually talk about
the console you're playing on yeah of
course when you look at titles on you
know PlayStation I I say toxic uh Fanboy
content
creators they're not talking about
PlayStation everything you see is what
Xbox didn't do right today what Xbox
didn't do right tomorrow like we get it
fam and you know let's let's before we
get on let's bring it up okay actually
you know what what we will talk about
that when we get to uh to to the
superhero thing let's talk about
Starfield Starfield
actually can I share my screen on this
thing yeah go to um present at the
bottom okay hold on let me let me share
to you guys what what's going on here
hold up I gotta find
it all right
so
I okay here it is all right so this is I
think I click this yeah okay
we're going to share my screen
yes okay there you go Bo there you
go all right so now you can blow it up a
little bit if you want to um of course
you know how to do it on your
keyboard control there you
go all right so as you guys could
see this is September this is first off
there was some Heavy Hitters out this
month
comat the new uh FIFA
2K yeah man that's crazy it beat those
games scarfield beat 2K like I
just I don't okay I don't play 2K so
maybe people in the chat and dirt you
can educate me is there a reason that
they're beating 2K because like even
payday 3 beat 2K and that's crazy yeah
uh you know I gotta be honest man as a
2K fan I'm a huge 2K guy
the game play is still solid as ever but
I believe they're going crazy with the
pay to win and a lot of people play on
the you know like the single player my
player stuff on the park and it's just
at the point if you don't have a lot of
money to spend on your character you
just can't compete with guys I bought
the $100 addition I used it I bought I
spent the extra $20 in my character was
still like a 76 and I'm playing against
guys that are like 94 95 and and know
just can't compete so maybe that's
getting around I don't know cuz it's
definitely pay to win and uh I don't
know man it I'm surprised I'm surprised
that not that Starfield necessarily beat
2K but I'm surprised a game like payday
three beat 2K you know what I'm saying
now the other games Mortal Kombat FIFA
you know
Madden that's that's not too surprising
but payday three beating 2K I don't know
man I think 2K is probably not too happy
with those numbers and then again maybe
they they sold what they normally sell
but this year you know pay Payday Two
the difference between two and three is
literally years I think it might even be
a decade so you know yeah I don't know
if that's uh what's going on here also
what's
interesting is the fact that
Madden the month after it came out still
sold well yeah well you know Madden
sells great
I haven't really bought a Madden in a
few years I I don't like him as much as
I used to I used to well I never really
care about Madden like maybe since the
PS1 generation I was always a 2K
football guy and ever since 2K football
it you know was not available anymore I
would buy Madden but I never really care
for him that much so I haven't I stopped
buying him last three four years I I
will play the 10hour ea uh access trial
and that's it I would never buy it I did
buy I think in 2020 maybe and I regret
it because I only play like one
game yeah and you know what what's
intense on here is that Starfield out
sold all these games for September
Mortal Kombat one bro and keep in mind
Starfield out sold all these games on
game
pass and don't forget it's also a new IP
and out of those out of the top
10 it's the only
um exclusive like I mean I know it's on
PC and Xbox but it's not on PlayStation
or Nintendo do you like how they put
Microsoft as the publ instead of
Bethesda hey it is what it is brother
yeah they're like we're gonna give that
one to Bethesda uh just like when it
comes to this this is cool but this next
one guys this next
one th this is this is
where it's it's crazy
this is the yearly stats right this is
the yearly one this is through through
oh let's be fair through
September yeah but
still you know what's funny is Starfield
is number seven dirt
seven and those are some bangers that's
ahead of it so we got hogw Works Legacy
number one which is interesting I didn't
know anything out so Zelda bro that hogw
Legacy man if you remember February that
hogw
bro PlayStation broke a record remember
because a lot of people thought that was
a damn exclusive because they marketed
it so great for the PS5 it so it it
moved units for the PlayStation in
February that game moved units
bro yeah and the thing that I want
people to like really look at is not
necessarily what beat Starfield because
there wasn't a lot Jedi Survivor which
is kind of interesting I'm really glad
that game sold well
um Call of Duty Diablo like everything
besides maybe Jedi Survivor and Hogwarts
Legacy got no business out selling
Starfield you know what I'm saying like
starfi got no business out selling they
are huge franchises even number one and
number uh uh six um adct those are huge
franchises if you think about
it it's like you said it's it's Star
Wars and in Harry Potter yeah use
franchises now I I I want to give more
shout out to Hogwart Legacy because this
is like the first big Harry Potter game
that's ever came out to this degree
right but let's get to the
Smoke Starfield might have been outsold
by Hogwart
Legacy uh Zelda Madden Diablo Call of
Duty
Jedi but Starfield
outsold Mortal Kombat
1 Resident Evil for the
Remake Dead Island 2 ml be the
show Final Fantasy
16 oh my God When I saw this dirt I
ain't gonna lie to you D I ain't gon lie
to you I was I was happy DT I was I was
ecstatic
dirt I I can't lie to you I can't stand
this damn
game like I really can't I can't stand
this oh man this game frustrates me to
no in because of how many people was
riding this game they and they're still
dying on this hill Final Fantasy 16 is
an okay game it's not a great
game and when you put that this game is
okay until you put that Final Fantasy
there once you put that Final Fantasy
it's got a different expectations let me
get these super chats real quick uh we
got a new member uh t t wank uh T wank
tank
89 we got a $2 Super Chat from chill
Carlos 343 has improved from 120 days to
27 days uh Seasons yeah that that's
what's up man it's like I said like I
think I think they're going to go up
from here you know as far as multiplayer
I'm just curious where that campaign
goes that's what I'm
curious we got Alvin with a$2 Super Chat
Spider-Man 2 and 90 Metacritic gonna be
an 89 come next week hey you see that
though that's true that that you know
Spider-Man creeped down to a 90 what do
you think the odds of it hitting an 89 I
think it's possible there's still a few
more websites um but I mean it might
stay out of 90 but it might go down I
mean it it doesn't matter I think the
game is you know going to be solid but
listen man I'm I will never forget the
way they treated
Starfield yeah you know who all these
trolls in here man goodness I don't even
see it because I'm on a different screen
yeah well I do don't worry about it yeah
just mods handle
that we got a $2 Super Chat from Jax 82
why is everyone coming at Starfield
because because it's one of the few
games that prevented them from attacking
Xbox what you just saying something oh
like T said it is 89 but no it's still a
bro oh oh it's he said it's an 89 yeah
but it's still a 90 oh you just yeah I
just okay
dude I was about to troll if it was I
ain't gonna lie I ain't gonna lie we got
a $2 super gamer by choice uh do they
count if you bought the upgrade only on
Game Pass I don't know I don't know if
they count that I'm I'm sure yeah well
that know that's a good question that's
a good question maybe uh hold let me see
because millions of like did like two
million people do that well well on Xbox
I think like a million people I don't
know how many people did it but that's a
good question I'm trying to see if Matt
said it somewhere
here I don't see
it
no I'm not looking through that
anymore yeah I don't know gamer uh by
choice that that's that's definitely a
good question I don't know yeah all
right
so yeah it's crazy Mario Kart's still on
this thing it's still on there that's
impressive though adct we I mean for to
beat Dead Space Resident Evil 4 Street
Fighter six I mean that's pretty damn
impressive man especially being on Game
Pass yeah right that's Ed on Game Pass
man and I I that's pretty impressive
FIFA that's
crazy what I'm kind of
curious is did the start did these games
just not sell what they normally did or
did so much more than than the average
game sells well you gotta realize this
is the NP FIFA Yeah well yeah what's it
called EA Sports FC 24 you know this is
the states FIFA sells well here but it
doesn't you know worldwide I'm sure it
didn't beat beat uh FIFA worldwide but I
mean still impressive man because FIFA
does sell well even here in the states
it sells pretty decently but this is
this is crazy man this is
crazy you it's crazy you look at this
um for for September Rainbow Six Siege
is still charting somehow those games as
a service man I I I believe that's what
play PlayStation wants if that game came
out of what 201 what 16 M and that's
what games as a service is right it's a
game that dropped years ago and it's
still being supported and people are
still playing it new people are are
coming to the product like fortnite or
whatever else I know fortnite is a free
to play but that's what you want Halo
infinite having a little boost with
season five is what people want Xbox
wants listen the game came out in 2021
it's obviously 2023 so two years later
people are still playing the games
people are still um loving the content
buying battle passes that's what
PlayStation wants they they look they
make great single player games but they
want to have a game like that they drop
like when Spider-Man comes out this
Friday it's going to do great no doubt
about it it's going to do great it's
going to sell well their abund sell
Starfield well they're they're bundling
it um so I don't know maybe yeah I
didn't know they're bundling it yeah
they Bund you you can't take its it's
its numbers did they bundle Starfield no
no that's straight no that's straight
sales bro um so when Spider-Man comes
out people going to love the game
they're going to beat it some guys are
going to platinum it and they're
probably not going to ever play it again
that's what Jim Ryan was saying he wants
no uh I mean not that but he wants them
to go back to play the game but just
having a little DLC or something that's
not a games as a service so games like
Rainbow Six fortnite Call of Duty war
zone even Halo infinite at this point
CFS man think about CFS came out of 2018
people they're about to be on season 10
bro so that's what PlayStation wants
some games like that because the single
player model is cool it was really cool
last gen and the PS3 gen but now these
games cost way too much and they need
that income that income coming in they
need that really bad right now yeah you
know it's it's kind of crazy like you
know I want to shift a little bit more
into the people that tried to character
assassinate Starfield was they attacked
it before the game even came
out you know they they they pretty much
said multiple times there's nothing you
can do that's going to make this game
good and what I want to really point out
is like all that hate that you guys
did didn't mean [__] not a damn thing
Brother game still sold well you guys
attacked it on Metacritic still sold
well and you know I'm kind of curious
what it sold like logistic numbers uh
because the fact that it out sold some
of the heaviest hitters the month that
came
out is is is is crazy to me and what's
funny
is it probably sold good in October
too so I'm kind of
curious if it's going to go up on that
seven list next month when the npds come
out next
month you know I think you're making
some great points and asking some good
questions
because I sat here and I watched those
guys going on a hate campaign for
Starfield I saw guys make eight straight
videos bashing Starfield we saw guys do
videos where they ran in one
direction for 10 minutes but they
claimed it well I for but for for 40
minutes but claimed it was 10 minutes
talking about an invisible wall even
after the game came out Phils Spencer
said we had 1 million concurrent players
that was before the game officially
released that was Early Access and
people still were saying that ain't [__]
if you remember like what are you guys
stupid guys didn't know what concurrent
players
meant even after the game was already
said it was a success by Microsoft
people still one on Twitter said
Starfield is a
failure I witnessed it I know all of the
people in the chat witnessed it they
still said Starfield was a failure
because of the Metacritic
score ah it's a 84 haha you bots can't
get a 90 game to save your life they
said the game was a
failure even though Field Spencer M
booty and everybody said the game is a
success we I'm sorry not M booty Tod
Howard they said the game we're
extremely happy with the the engagement
we've seen with
Starfield they still said it ain't
nothing concurrent players what is that
aha that ain't nothing one million
concurrent players ain't nothing
Spider-Man sold three million do you
know what concurrent players mean
dummy so here you go look at you now
like why so serious
said yeah you know what's funny if you
look at
um where they were last night I don't
know where they are now someone in the
chat look up if you want to where they
are on Steam charts it was like the top
10 or top
15 and and it's like they're still
pulling like
67,000 live viewers in an hour
and oh I mean a day I don't know if they
go by hours or not so it's like people
would sit there and hate all you want
you know there's certain times where
being hating like that helps the the
game more than it hurts it like I would
say that's one of the reasons Harry
Potter sold so well m is because you
know it was attacked so much and a lot
of people defended it buying it just
just to you know go against that
movement because they didn't believe in
it and it's just like you know attacking
Starfield for no reason isn't going to
help you guys it's not look at this
idiot in the chat bro David he said but
concurrent doesn't stay that way
forever but three million sales does
what is wrong with you concurrent means
1 million people was playing at the same
time the same
time 3 million sales could be 3 million
people bought it maybe for a gift maybe
they just bought it just to have it
maybe they bought it you you don't
understand you ponies y'all relying on
metal crit scores for your console war
banter at this point that's it y'all
have console sales and metac crit score
us to talk somebody left a comment on
Twitter I want to get a guy props his
name is the eyes of the prophet he said
PlayStation games are reviewed by
PlayStation Fanboys Nintendo games are
reviewed by Nintendo Fanboys Xbox games
are reviewed by PlayStation
Fanboys got a point there he got a damn
good
point so y'all go ahead Metacritic
scores is y'all fence and look I'm not
saying listen I know Spider-Man is gonna
be a solid game because assc is a great
developer but that's all y'all have that
in sales and when you guys really
realize that casuals is who's buying the
PS5 right now because the damn show
ain't hardcore Gamers because if
hardcore Gamers was buying the PS5
balers Gate 3 wasn't been 20 if not
would it for the PS5 not would it as
much as y'all cap for that game that
game is 20 is 20th on the PlayStation 5
in
September all the crap y'all said Bo
this game destroying Starfield look at
20th I'm sorry I had to go ahead bro so
I want to talk about this you know we're
we we'll still stay on the topic of
Starfield I do feel like this
conversation's important
because right now I feel like we're good
but
where do you think the game of the year
conversation is going to go because the
reason I want to wait a week is because
we don't know if these nominations going
to drop between now and next Wednesday
so it's it's it's an interesting
conversation it is there's a huge
conversation right now going in the uh
in the community on whether or not
Starfield hits that game of the year
Contender because how stacked this year
has be yeah so what's your opinion on
that conversation that's a valid
question man I um initially I thought it
was like a a guarantee it would be in
the
nominations I I I wasn't sure it was
going to win especially with Zelda and
bers gate but I feel the game should be
at least nominated and um right now I
I'm not sure but I still think it will
be nominated but how things work in this
industry I'm not sure you can say the
guaranteed Zelda balers Gate 3 I no
Spider-man 3 I mean two will probably be
there now um Starfield should be there
but then there's another like some
smaller games like C of what it C of
stars that's that's getting incredibly
great reviews and we still you know like
what else do we have left I don't that's
probably it but I'm I'm not sure if it's
going to be nominated it definitely
should be oh right Hogwarts warts that's
another game um so I'm not
sure but I believe it should at least be
nominated I apologize guys I'm getting a
headache I had to turn that light off
you're just going to have to to see me a
little darker today like it's just uh I
stare at the screen too long I need
those like Gunner glasses whatever
things
called yeah so look okay Russ could
possibly be there potentially it
probably won't but would you be upset if
high five Rush got on there and starf
didn't if high five Rush was able to get
on there because like the Indie thing
like the smaller title thing but starfi
didn't get on there
I mean that' be that' be you know that'
be something to talk about but I think
it should be at least nominated
definitely like I said it probably won't
win because of the games that we have
this year I think balers Gate 3 has a
solid chance you know Zelda always has a
solid chance but you know we'll see what
happens yeah I
think I think that we
look
Spider-Man to a
degree I ain't played
it so I'm gonna put that aside but
Boulders gate and
Zelda are the only two games right now
that I know
of that belongs in their
guaranteed guaranteed yeah those two
guar at least four that's
open now normally they like to give an
indie game in this every year yeah but I
feel like this might be the year they
change that you think so like like you
don't think C Stars has a chance or high
five rush I know it's not Andy but you
know what would be crazy if Jeff wants
Final Fantasy 16 in there and I know he
doesn't do this but I'm I'm I'm deciding
the narrative today okay if they put
Final Fantasy fin fantasy 16 in there
but he gives he gives he gives us high
five rush to make up for it no you give
a St for if
just imagine if he put Final Fantasy 16
in there and not Starfield bro yeah
that's a if 16's not in there and
starfields not in
there I won't kicking screen I'll be
like okay because that's the only game
now here's the thing besides those two
games because I do feel like especially
Boulders gate now I I personally feel
like Starfield is a better game than
Zelda I love Zelda but I feel like
starfields is a more unique experience
it's a better game than Zelda I do not
think Boulder Gate's a better game than
Z I mean I do not think Zelda uh Boulder
gate is uh Starfield is better than it I
do think you know Boulder's Gate is a is
a better game than Starfield so with
that being said but I can understand why
people are going to give Zelda it's it's
it's ignorant not to assume zeld is
going to be in
there so that's
two now we got got people put in the
chat games that you think would be in uh
game of the year so I can bounce off the
CH a little bit I saw D Togo say
Resident Evil 4 remake it's a great game
I don't think it should be in Game of
the Year because it's a 2004 game just
remade just that's me personally though
I think Resident Evil 2 was was an
outliner because it was one of the no
I'm talking about Resident Evil 2 oh
okay the two remake it was an outliner
because how was nominated yes it was
nominated oh well okay it great game
though it was the first game that came
back in that kind of way yeah and it was
amazing it was amazing uh so let's see
uh Liza P I don't think that's going to
be there even though a lot of people
like that game Mario wonder do you think
Mario wonder you think they it's a 95
Med creative I don't think they're gonna
put two Nintendo games in it though why
if they put Mario in there instead of
Zelda yeah I mean it it's a 95 medic I
don't think they're going to put two
Nintendo games though that would be
crazy somebody said red
hey
hey who shot you show some respect
talking about red
fall all right so I think I'm G
do hey yo slow-mo I agree I believe
there's too many original games or or
sequels um I don't think the remakes or
or or like remasters should be included
this year I agree with you bro yeah
because here's my thing like I
understand what's going on and and
people feel of the
year uh we've been talking about this
what it's it's 47
minutes uh I'm gonna say we've been
talking about this for five minutes
we'll say 39 oh man we almost hour into
the show bro this can't going fast today
yeah so here here's the thing like
I agree I don't think that we should be
giving remakes of any sort into this
like it should be strictly just newer
games like I don't care I understand
Final Fantasy uh not Final Fantasy I
understand that Resident Evil was a
great game and I don't think no one's
really going to like argue that it's not
a good
game yeah and that that's part of like
where I'm at with the situation where
it's like I just want what's
fair and and I don't I don't
think a game even though it was
good it was still just a carbon copy of
something that came out years ago
yeah and to me that's not fair in the in
in the slightest that a game because to
me you know I agree with you by the way
newer experience is something that H
that was made from the ground up that's
not the case for
this yeah this game isn't made from the
ground up it had something that it went
off of now Spider-Man's a big game and I
think Spider-Man's definitely in there
so I I'll give the third one you know so
that leasts
three Diablo
4 do you think that makes
it for some oh that's a good question I
feel like you had a lot lot of hate
coming out the gate with it it it was
fine with it first launch but that
didn't last long
yeah I
mean if they don't include an indie
which I believe they
will uh diabo should probably be in
there but since they're probably going
to include Indie I'm G to say no it
shouldn't be in
there okay so we still have okay
hogwart's Legacy I say
no yeah yeah probably not even though it
was a very good game I didn't finish it
but it was a solid game okay what about
Mario wonders does it take a forth or
does it take Zelda
slot I don't think they're gonna have
two Nintendo games in there that would
just be crazy um I don't think it's
gonna be in there I don't think it's
gonna take Zelda slot okay you know how
upset people would be if it took Zelda
spot yeah people I don't think because
it's a solid game but it's not the
additional Mario right like the next
Mario game right it's just a 2d I mean
it you know it it looks fine but it's
not the the next Mario Mario game right
it's not like the next like like what
was the last Mario game
Odyssey yeah yeah it's not like the next
big Mario game is it it's like a side
piece kind of like a side Mario game I
don't see it is it is a big game but
it's not like I would say like their big
capitalizations they do is stuff like um
Odyssey yeah you know stuff like that I
think that would be it it is the next
big game but I don't think it's you know
the game that we would like Captivate
towards like I'm still gonna play
wonders because me and King got like
some content we're going to do before it
but to me a big Mario game would be a 3D
Mario game right yeah but I do because
people are saying no wonder is their
next big Mario game and that is but I I
feel like Wonder there's a difference
between the games like Wonder and the
games like
um in the games like Odyssey I think
there's a huge
difference all right
so forzo Motorsport no that's not gonna
be there no okay so people are giving
like their whole thing this dude thinks
Starfield Spider-Man 2 Boulder uh bers
Gate 3 tear of the Kingdom Mario wonder
and uh maybe high five rusher CF Stars
that's a solid list that's a solid list
yeah but see it's leaving out Final
Fantasy 16 which I I'm up for that ain't
gonna be there Al that Final Fantasy 16
is not g to be there brother U I would
actually say this list right here guys
this is the
list Spider-Man two balers gate three
Zelda Mario wonder I think that's a
that's a good list um I believe CF Stars
will probably make it over high five
rush though and but I still don't think
I don't think they should have let two
Nintendo games be in there that's I mean
I guess technically if you just want to
go by the metal creit scores but me
personally I don't think two Nintendo
games should be in there here's the
thing
people how bad you think it is that
starfields L on on
nominated oh you say how how how bad how
bad would I be or how bad no how bad is
the Xbox Community gonna behave at this
game we gonna be pissed
we gonna be
pissed now okay I will only join the
Xbox Port uh uh the Xbox pitchforks if
they put 16 in there not Starfield if
you know okay maybe a Hogwarts Legacy
because I do generally feel like
starfields a way Superior game than
Hogwarts Legacy but if they put Resident
Evil Spider-Man Boulders gate
Diablo
um Zelda and wonders I wouldn't really
say too much because I do feel like
those games you can make a huge argument
why Starfield is not on that list but if
and you know obviously if you say when
it comes to like having two Nintendo
games on there so if you put those games
on there I'm fine but if I see any Final
Fantasy
16s or or or or anything else that I
personally feel because this is about my
game of the year okay and in order for
in order for the for for it to come to
truth they got to put the game ey fills
on there and that's why I personally
feel
like it would be a travesty to see Final
Fantasy 16 go on that I'm sorry I just
don't I don't think that game deserves
there it just doesn't it just doesn't
doesn't at all I don't even think that's
in a conversation adct I really that's
not in conversation bro if people like
to call this thing the PlayStation
Awards like they got Spider-Man
Spider-Man too will be there I don't
think Final Fantasy 16 should be in a
conversation um I personally feel like
Jeff NOS what's up Jeff
knows I might not canot I will be
tweeting you won't see me tweet I might
make you won't see me tweet unless 16's
on there now you see 16 and star fils on
there I'm
tweeting what's going to be the game
that's like like last year the game
immortality I actually beat that game
and I still don't know how the hell I
finished it um that game was a game that
got nominated but you knew it had no
chance of winning it had
z.0 chance of
winning what would that game be this
year see stars yeah yeah to be honest
with you if you ain't balers gate or
Zelda I think you don't really got it's
either balers gate or Zelda it's gonna
be I think balers gate gonna win this
year you know what be funny if Mario
Wonders on because it's got recency
bias oh
man yeah immortality is on Netflix yeah
I finished that game I still I still
didn't understand that game bro I just
didn't someone said you guys don't think
high five Rush can be nominated it's
either high five rush or sea stars will
be in that in that spot if they do go
with your traditional like Indie thing
yeah but I think there's enough Indies
every year where Jeff may just need to
make an indie game of the year I think
so too because I feel like you're you're
deliberately
setting like some of these Indie
developers up just to lose like it's an
auto loss like you know imagine to see a
Stars got you know they're they're going
to be hyped that they got voted for game
of the year but it's just like they know
they're not winning that you know what
I'm saying right
100% hey yeah slow-mo I you know it was
very weird I played it for about six to
seven hours bro I you know I like those
I guess what you call them real movies
or real games I should say with with
real people I you know just I just
didn't get it the three different
movies but I somehow finished it bro it
was totally by luck the achievement
popped up I was like damn I finished it
I just want what what's well if that's
why I said like certain games get on
there over Starfield okay but I don't
want to see I don't even think Diablo
deserves on that point but I there there
was some hiccups with Starfield so I
can't act like there wasn't but that's
why I'm not really I wouldn't really say
too much it wasn't a perfect game yeah
if Diablo's on there over
Starfield but you better not let me
catch that fin F 16 I don't think you're
gonna be on addict I Think You're
Paranoid brother I don't think won't be
there I'm putting a poll poll in the
chat right now going down no way Final
Fantasy 16 is there bro Po in the
chat is
ff16 going to be Game of the Year
Contender no yes
no what
addicts Allan way to well we haven't
seen any reviews yet it's possible it
could you know be there if it's really
really good we'll see because that's
really like because you know Call of
Duty ain't gonna never be there that's
really the biggest game left we got
right the RPG game I don't know Mario
RPG I think that might be too late
though no
is knows winning which it should be
winning so far I hope so man yeah you
know I think that it's like I said you
can the only games that would push
Starfield out of the contenders to me
100% would be Zelda and Boulder's Gate
you know I don't think even Spider-Man
to a degree you know Spider-Man offers a
different experience in Starfield and
you know you can argue that Spider-Man
probably is the more objective better
game because it does the things that it
put out does better than Starfield but I
wouldn't say like indefinitely Starfield
is a better game than Spider-Man I think
that is a subjective opinion between
people was Spider-Man did did Spider-Man
2018 get nominated yes it did yeah this
one will most likely honestly it
probably should be nominated um but I
think Starfield should be too I don't
think Starfield will win I think this is
B's gate year this is larryan Studio's
year but I do believe it should be
nominated and if starford doesn't get
nominated then you know we we I will
join the Blazing on on Twitter if Final
Fantasy is part of that but if it's not
I'm going sit back I'm going sit back
and just eat my popcorn and watch the
fires of Twitter go you really you you
really concerned about Final Fantasy 16
I am I am I I every time I see someone's
list Final Fantasy 16's in it like every
single time really yeah hold up I wonder
if I can just look up Game of the Year
nomination
sure if Final Fantasy 16 is nominated
and Starfield is
not oh it's gonna be crazy
man all right so let me see let me see
if I could just look up Game of the Year
on Twitter and see if I can bring up
everyone's thing they're
doing all right so it's not perfect but
we'll we'll look through this can you
see it when I share my screen to you did
you share yet not yet yeah okay can you
see this yes
sir all right
so so uh Allan Wake for some reason I
don't I don't I don't know why he put
that there what he say if Allan Wake to
delivers Spiderman wonders sea stars
Boulders gate
Zelda um after huh can you zoom in a
little bit I can't see it too work
thanks okay so we
got
Mario we got Spider-Man Jedi Survivor oh
see Final Fantasy 16 I'm telling you I
see this [__] everywhere I go on his
page I guarantee he's a
pony he's not following anyone I'm
following uh Game of the Year final
fantasy 16 like these are ponies man I
guarantee it not following anyone I
follow uh this is a Nintendo person
so Final Fantasy 16 I'm telling you
Pony okay okay okay this dude look like
he actually know what he talking about
no 16 I feel like this is what you're
generally gonna see you're going to
replace Starfield and maybe Mario
wonders with other games but I think
that's probably what you're going to see
is is around
this
yeah ohy I would be surprised if Final
Fantasy 16 make it I really would yeah
I'm telling you a lot of people think
that that that is it's it's happening
like okay so bers gate I think bers gate
is winning also I really
do this is another alternative I'm
telling you giving his high-f five rush
to put in another bigger game for uh
over
Starfield high five Rush has a solid
chance I just think like the three three
guarantees Baler gate Zelda and
Spider-Man too in my opinion Starfield
should be a guarantee shobi thinks Final
Fantasy 16's in there
Pony
16 okay 16 even Paris thinks 16's in
there oh my God BG
16 I knew you was gonna say 16 for
VG oh
man yeah me you know do one more Final
Fantasy 16 oh come on you know that
tiger you know he a pony bro 16 Pony
Final Fantasy 16 these are ponies aleec
I just don't what
the what games are those I don't know I
don't know Final Fantasy
16 it's just crazy how many who Persona
hearts come on
man yeah that's a
pony is that is that
the a lot of these people know okay this
is is a Nintendo dude he says 16s
there yeah I told you a lot of these
people in there 16 but the only thing
you didn't mention that it's all ponies
that's saying
that oh my God all right let's get this
that's the only thing $5 super from Jay
uh uh if Final Fantasy 16 16's nomin
over starford every bot on the planet
should Riot I'm sharpening my Pitchfork
as we speak just just in case you better
make sure I'm tell you right now if that
happen if that happen if they nominated
Final Fantasy 16 and not Starfield you
might see me talk [__] y'all can say
dirt crying because I'mma be up here
like going crazy that's some big ass
this is crazy you know that that would
be crazy bro that that's my only fear is
is they get when is the nominations
announced early December oh one was last
year's announced let me see uh Video
Game
Awards I think it's usually early
December I think it's early November for
some reason I feel like we know about
the nominations for like a
month but someone in the chat tell me
this year like I really let's SK this
one real quick $2 Super Chat from J 82
Final Fantasy 16 has 60 frames they will
consider
it all right let's get let's get to why
the people are
here uh let me do the time stance real
quick I
course one hour and five minutes oh
which is interesting we started last
week this uh on the last topic the exact
same time we started this
week
all
right Spider-Man 2 metac Dr and I made a
video and I was just pretty much saying
that you know I personally think that
Microsoft needs to Captivate and be in
the superhero market
and the Xbox people they they showed up
they they they didn't show up with me
they showed up against me
you know it was it was it was it was
definitely a dog pile on attic
and dirt was right there front center of
my he was saying I'mma see you Wednesday
he pretty much told me I been see you
outside so
D I'm GNA let you start this
conversation to defend yourself because
you are the Challenger not all right let
me say this I am not not against Xbox
having an exclusive superhero game what
I didn't like what I didn't agree with
was the way you said it they need a
superhero game let me ask you a
question um besides Spider-Man what was
the last extremely successful superhero
game DC or
Marvel DC uh DC Batman okay and was what
in 200
what um KN came out in what
year
2015 I don't know I'll look it up yeah
it was
Batman
KN we've had yes 2015 several superhero
games big superhero games that
flopped
Avengers uh Gotham Knights Guardians of
the
Galaxy guard G Squad got Guardians of
the Galaxy was uh raved on the people
yeah but it was still it didn't sell it
didn't sell it was so bad that that
Square Enix said we don't want these
Studios anymore but scar Enix has a
habit of doing that though it doesn't
matter they were not happy with the
results and listen a lot of people bash
The Avengers I thought it was a decent
game I love Guardians of the Galaxy I
actually thought um nice was decent but
my point is
this just imagine
if you doing everything you can as a
husband yall got a nice house you got a
nice car you got a you know you keep
food in the house you have a job all you
your LIC and B your gas never gets cut
off you're doing a good job as a man
then your wife say I know we got all
these nice things we got a nice car but
I want a Mercedes
bans like damn you you ain't
happy my thing is this I'm not against
them having an exclusive superhero game
but you said they
need they
need a superhero
game that's clearly your
opinion my thing is Xbox went from five
Studios to
32 they have first person shooters they
have what West RPGs they are trying to
get in some more jrpgs on their console
they're doing everything they can to
make the Xbox band brand better because
we always say that was their weakness
last generation lack of first party
titles they have new IP they have Gams
out of service that they're continuing
to
support and to
hear
Xbox y'all
need to have a superhero game now let's
be real like I said I'mma say it again
I'm not against Xbox having an exclusive
superhero game that' be cool just like
they're gonna have an exclusive Indiana
Jones game that's
cool but when you say it exactly after
Spider-Man 2 reviews come
out you you had the XBox guys like adct
bro
add it come on
man like Spiderman is
Spiderman Batman is
Batman what do Xbox have to do to make
people
happy I understand you can't make
everybody happy but come on bro that's
what some of the Xbox homies because I
got a lot of DMs like what's up with
your boy adct man what's up with your
boy ad I said look
man cuz when I saw when your video
popped up in my notific I was like oh
come on man you and what's funny is like
we've argued about this on this this
show before yeah we
have listen and listen I know Spider-Man
too is a bang I know Wolverine's gonna
be a good guy and you're probably gonna
do another video like that again when
comes out of 2025 I'll probably
re-upload this one with that one right
so I'm a say for the fourth time in this
rant I'm not against Xbox having a an
exclusive superhero
game
but there are so many other things that
I feel is more
important um than for
Xbox Xbox is playing the long game
Spider-Man 2 great
game
but
Xbox I mean they can do that but I'm put
the emphasis on the word need I don't
think they need
a superhero game do we want one sure but
I don't think they need
one okay so let me get these super chats
real quick and then and then I'll give
my
re gamer by choice I'm gonna point out
that he is agreeing with thir uh thir I
agree see told you just because
Spider-Man is awesome and sells well
does not mean any other franchise would
do as well
needs a Starfield Choice PlayStation
needs a Starfield type of
game then we got a $5 from wooden thr he
agrees with me by the way everyone knows
who Spider-Man and Wolverine are even if
you're not a gamer draws attention to
the brand and snaker golden addict is
right all right so let
me first off let's
address the need part m
I have a reason why I feel like they
need it and the biggest reason that I
feel like they need it is it's on
different
fronts I think we can
agree that Microsoft's doing a better
job at captivating mainstream audience
but they can do better and I feel like a
welldone superhero game will do just
that do they need that no but I feel
like that is one of the good things it
can do because regardless even how bad
Marvel has done still popular that's
that's one side my second side is I
personally feel
like Sony is is putting a lot of money
behind Marvel MCU and I feel like in
their
mind they're going to continue to
Captivate off of the hype that the MCU
continues to generate now
now to your
point MCU isn't where it used to be
they've definitely went down ever since
ingame but I feel like right now that
might just be how the story is is
unwinding we don't know what's gonna
happen with K we don't know how they're
going to build that that that that
villain up and all it takes is one or
two really good movies to get them right
back on top in terms of movies
now let's say Sony bets all this money
and it doesn't work
MCU doesn't bounce
back then I feel like your justification
definitely 100% valid
but if MCU doesn't bounce if they do
bounce back and they've already started
all this little stuff to building their
own MCU on their console I feel like
when Microsoft had a thorn in their in
their their their they just had thorns
on them you know they could have fixed
it there by making their own turned into
Gang Green they losing an arm now
because you can react to stuff better if
you prepare for it for the worst than
reacting stuff to better than when it's
already too late for
instance Sony and
Insomniac might be building the next
type of MCU hype goes on when they bring
Wolverine and then that goes into black
panther and that goes into whoever they
decide and they start putting them
together and then they're making Avenger
games could this happen
yes we don't
know but when you go back all all the
way to the original Iron
Man you looking at that perspective I
bet you the movie theater and DC never
expected ingame never expected the
direction and the
trajectory that Marvel was going at the
time because they were playing off of
we're GNA focus on our stuff we're not
building universes we're not doing this
we're not doing that my
fear is that Microsoft is betting on the
on the fan that look they'll be f they
they still have uh you know Elder
Scrolls they have Indiana Jones which I
think that's a good chance in the right
direction of media with mainstream media
but I'm
worried that they won't try to go into
the the the the superhero Direction and
by the time they start to actually
entertain that
ideal Sony's made like five or six
superhero games they've already combined
Wolverine's doing a game with Spider-Man
then before you know it they're doing
they're doing an X-Man thing with
Spider-Man's in it and then at that time
we're talking about a way worse scenario
because they've built a universe where
people are playing all of the games to
generate one narrative
story now if this doesn't happen I 100%
agree with you but I fly P to
me feel
like it doesn't take much with all the
studios they have they can make a hero
game they can get into this and and I I
feel you to a point like and I wasn't
saying that they need this like dire
need I feel like they need this because
they're trying to because they need to
prepare for the future that I believe in
saiacs making that's just me that I
believe that they are going towards
because I think we are seeing the
foundations to what to to what Marvel
built in the early 2000s we're seeing
the early foundations now with
insomnia I wouldn't be surprised if
Spider-Man 2 does well Wolverine does
well if they if insomnic branches out
multiple teams they start making
multiple games like a Wolverine game on
top of that then like I said then they
eventually revisit the Avengers that's
my
word I just don't want Microsoft in a
position five to years down the line
that because they didn't act
sooner they can't compete with them on
SP Superman and on superheroes and like
you said the
MCU they could never bounce back and
this isn't an issue but I do think being
the only place you can go to playing
superhero games on that caliber is an
issue for
Microsoft may maybe not now but it could
be an issue that things work well for
not only the MCU but insomniac's Future
Wolverine game and Spider-Man when it
was just Spider-Man I felt like they
needed to compete with Spider-Man but
now the reason I'm pushing more for it
is because I feel like they needed to
compete with this MC universe that
that's that Sony is building lowkey on
their platform when I saw Wolverine pop
up on their stage I said this is gonna
be an issue if they don't address it
there you go Wolverine is going to be
another solid game right I believe
they're not building anything I believe
Wolverine is going to be over reading
correct I think you're over I think
Wolverine is going to be a pretty good
game probably dropping in
2025 um I believe Spider-Man the formula
you can only do so much with it like if
they do a Spider-Man 3 what they gonna
do different they have Spider-Man go to
La but like like I mean so my point is
this
there they have always been uh superhero
games for years years they always
multiplat and none of them really killed
it until you know maybe Wolverine um
game they came out for the 360 those
games were
good most wolver I'm tell you Mo most
superhero games were movie tie-ins or
just some Spiderman um games back in the
Genesis Super Nintendo Batman games my
thing is there's always been superhero
games and Spider-Man is pretty much
because it's an exclusive it seems to be
getting more love from PlayStation fans
but Spider-man is Spider-man he's
literally one of the most popular
superheroes there is and I get you on
that standpoint in order to compete with
Spider-Man they couldn't just get a hero
it have to be a like if not on the same
level as Spider-Man around that same
level talking we're talking like black
panther um Iron Man Captain America like
they would have to get someone that hire
Batman they just had a game with those
characters adct and nobody car they just
had a game with those characters you
just mentioned Hawke Thor
Spider-Man black panther black widow and
nobody gave it there do you think the
game would have been better if Saw made
it though probably it I thought it was a
good game I thought the forc games out
the service hurt the game cuz Crystal
Dynamics is a quality
developer but all I'm saying is
that it's going to take long time to
build this this franchise or this this
thing that you're saying they're going
to have and I just don't think it's
going to happen Disney's already given
their games they're making EA's making
an Iron Man game and the Black Panther
game I feel you it and you know this
would put variables on the those games
are successful or not uh but I do think
that if Wolverine and Spider-Man 2 are
mad successful that yeah g to be
successful Sony could have a lot of like
leeway to lock down that whole
genre I mean I I just don't think it's
it's as urgent or is going to be as big
of a deal as you think it is just just
my opinion and I don't think that this
is something that would prevent them
from competing on a huge scale but I do
think that if it goes this way and they
they they are able to make their own you
know Universe in the future I think it
would be one of the things that would
that would be a huge Thorn on their side
now obviously if they build their own
franchises out it would level out but
you know I put more
faith in popular stuff being really good
because when it comes to mainstream you
know how they are they they move where
the crowd is and and it's just like you
know Elder Scrolls might be big in our
sectors in our gaming circles but when
you put that in the mainstream nobody
knows outside of gaming what Elder
Scrolls is they might know know they
might know what Skyrim is but they don't
know what Elder Scrolls are but people
know what Spiderman is what Batman is
what true you know X man are they they
know what these are they and to a point
I you know people said spawn in the chat
I don't think people know who spawn is
to that SP spawn isn't big enough yeah
but that's just my opinion my opinion is
Sony's in the middle stage the the the
beginning stages of trying to fill out
their own type of you know MCU Universe
cannot work we don't know we don't know
what would happen but my mindset
is if you can find the right
studio and you can start building these
block pieces especially of DC James gun
has said that they're rebooting the
entire DC Universe and and that their
games is going to be part of the lore of
their movies yeah so to me that's the
perfect thing pop over there and be like
we'll fund the game side just make the
most on our side I got one question did
Spider-Man 2018 Miles Morales did it
kill
Xbox no but I can can we agree though
that Spider-Man Miles moral and
Spider-Man
2 have came out and consumed all the
Internet space at the time they came out
all I'm saying is just because you don't
necessarily need it in the landscape you
have now doesn't mean you won't need it
in the
future you know they don't necessarily
need Call of Duty they're doing it
because they need it for their bottom
line in the
future okay okay let me ask you this
Spider-Man comes out Friday
right what was talked about more by
PlayStation Fanboys Starfield or
Spider-Man
Starfield I feel you on that but you can
flip that on its side too like look like
at the end of the day I just I don't
want them being caught off guard and I
do feel
like sometimes s
corporations they don't look at what
necessarily could happen like in terms
of mainstream they don't look at Trends
they look at what's making money now
that's why you see so many games like
Marvel Avengers Anthem so many games
felling as a games as a service because
they're trying to copy the games as a
service now and not trying to estimate
where the games of service going to go a
couple years from now and they're and
they're just falling over their own feet
and to
me if Sony is able to Captivate and
build an MCU correctly on like a like a
PlayStation exclusive
MCU it's not that that's not going to be
impossible to combat it's just going to
give PlayStation a huge advantage in the
future but like like you said that's if
they can do that there's no definition
and like you even said too they we don't
even have really whole lot
of of evidence that they're even trying
to do that but to me seeing Wolverine
out there there's no way that Insomniac
and Marvel and Sony are not looking at
that if Wolverine and Spider-Man come
out in their very successful Games
should put them together should make a
Wolverine and Spider-Man game and I just
feel like that is when The Dominoes will
start falling over where by the time
Microsoft's like man we
we should have did something sooner uh
you know and you know it's it's like how
I feel about when it comes like the Evo
thing Microsoft doesn't need a
fighter but it's better for them to have
one because they're in that space and
their a conversation in that that law
that that genre they don't need it
because they need it for their uh for
their bottom line they need it to be
present in that conversation because if
you're not in the conversation you're
never going to be the highlight of the
conversation
I don't think Xbox is worried about it I
really don't I think their focus is
building their
Library continuing to invest making game
pass as attractive as it can be in
making
money that's I think that's their focus
I don't think their
focus is
on let me repeat myself before I
continue I'm not saying I don't want
them to have a superhero game and
exclusive superhero I'm not saying I
don't want them to do that I'm just
talking
about the need for them to have a
superhero
game saying that you particularly would
like for them to have a superhero game
but at the end of the day you don't
think they need it to continue it's like
I said my my argument's off spe
speculation on what's going on my
argument's off of what might be not what
is so I if if things continue the way it
is now and they don't really try to
build that kind of univers
then they wouldn't really have an issue
but if and to your point like the last
time we had MCU might never ever bounce
back we may never have another we may
never have another moment that was
like Advengers in game or Avengers
Infinity war and it might never be to
the point it is now but I'm sure if you
go over there and you ask DC when they
were starting their little stuff they
would say I wish we did things
differently oh 100% 100% but let me tell
you this my daughter's a perfect example
she got into MCU so strong bro she loved
it after end game you know we watched
the little TV shows on Disney plus my
daughter's at the point now she can care
less about any of it she just she just
didn't like she didn't like the uh the
um Doctor Strange movie She I mean I
thought it was okay but the Marvel she
has no is even going to see it so it's
like they might need to reboot which I
believe they're going to DC is in the
midst of rebooting so they're still
making games for these
characters but I'mma say this again we
cannot
forget we had a few we had a few
superhero games that did not do well in
the last five
years Spiderman and Batman there are no
but okay Spider-Man Batman
Superman are the top three easily right
Wolverine is like right there far as
like B tier he's pretty popular too
after Wolverine and the X-Man as a whole
what happens who else can move the what
other superhero can move the needle we
say black panther possibly possibly I
think black panther became popular
because of the movies but because like
before that you know black panther was a
character we didn't know much about same
thing Iron Man we knew of him we knew of
Tony Stark but those are the comic book
heads that knew of him
Wolverine I love W he's one of my
favorite
characters but is he going he's not
Spider-Man I tell you that Spider-Man is
the most popular superhero bro Batman is
probably second Superman probably third
after
that the boys I love that show by the
way do you because I think we've had
this conversation you have stated that
you would have liked for Microsoft to
buy Warner Brother in the past
absolutely what what what what would
there be justification to BU Warner
Brother it was what like First all
number one was
nether okay that was the number one
reason I was saying buy one of the
brothers because you know Mortal Kombat
yeah that was the number one reason but
o um actually also they're like rock
steady I don't know what's up Rock
Steady they were super talented I'm
assuming they're still talented but we
know brother that last game came out in
20 what
15 it's it's the the next game is coming
out
2024 all right so let's say they buy
Warner Brother next would you be more
open to them entertaining Super Hero
games because they actually have tools
to do it with or is your issue you don't
want them going out of their way to do
it no see you need see you're you're
misunderstanding me I'm always I'm open
for it now but it was the way you said
said the word
need that's all I'm talking about I'm
open for it now but you said they need
no they don't need will it be nice yes
but they don't need a superhero game it
will be nice but because I don't believe
at this point superhero games are more
important than what Xbox has in the
future yes superhero gang Spider-Man
going to move some units bro it's going
to sell Spider-Man is going to sell
and then we're going to be waiting for
Wolverine for another year and a half
that's it I guess to me besides like the
fear of them like combining IPS and
stuff it's just like I want Microsoft to
be more into the mainstream media you
know they tried that with Halo and I
felt like that was you know kind of a
let down to me you know I think Star
Wars maybe MCU like having a couple
exclusive games on their platform that
is from a big IP and and you know
Bethesda we're doing with Indiana Jones
and that's good I I think to me it's
like you know especially with the DC
stuff I remember the the old days with
Batman Arkham Asylum and Arkham City and
you know when 2018 Spider-Man came out
like the captivating audience that
happened with that and I feel like
Microsoft would definitely benefit from
that you know could I used better words
than need
sure but I do feel like they need a
mainstream audience I feel like they
need to be more in the conversation when
people are talking about you know you
know the big culture stuff that's going
on right now uh let me get this Super
Chat that that slow-mo said because I
think it's a it's a good Super Chat uh
slow-mo said um I'm like 10 minutes
behind but there are more hero IPS and
wor uh worth making from than just
Marvel and DC what about an incredible
okay agree Invincible Invincible inin I
don't think that move the needle bro I
like how he's DLC in in like Mortal
Kombat I don't think that move the
needle like only the big three in my
opinion and maybe a couple other
superheroes can really move the needle
so let me ask you this then if they made
a wellone Superman
game they like contracted rock steady
and like rock steady got on they they
stuff they banded in like the the games
the service stuff they made a really
good
superhero game and that popped up on on
Xbox do you think that would help move
the needle for Xbox yeah sure that would
definitely help them because I feel like
just being able to promote that you have
a high quality good narrative super May
superhero uh Superman game on your
platform just the marketing alone would
be extremely beneficial to Xbox yeah
like to me they you know you can argue
if they need it or not but I would say
the brand definitely needs more of that
mainstream audience over there you know
even something like Lords of uh you know
even shadow of mortal and Shadow Of War
people love those games right right
because they're making a Wonder Woman
game actually monolith they're making a
one I actually forgot about that I saw
somebody mention in the chat they're
making a Wonder Woman game monol at at
WB over there so you know I
think I think there's a middle ground on
this
um what would the conditions because
like right here I want to know because
you said they don't need it so how would
you want them if they came to you and
they said and they said D we need to
make uh what should we do in terms of
the superhero if you had the the the
rights to tell them how to go about it
what would you
say first all he depends on what
superhero if they can't get Spider-Man
we go to D
right Batman is the like I said Batman
is really no one one that can move the
needle in my opinion they they haven't
had a Superman game since what 2006
Superman Returns Superman games don't
work because he too op I guess um gotth
them
Knights didn't do well I saw Aaron put
that in there that game didn't do well
so if they wanted to go to super here
rout I wouldn't know what this I
wouldn't know man I mean it's at this
point I just don't
know if superhero games are going to
remain well Spider-Man games will be
successful but we just don't know if
superhero games are going to still be
successful because like I mentioned
earlier the last three nine Spider-Man
or nine Batman superhero games flop bro
what about Mandalorian people putting
that in the
chat that's cool I guess SPID Star Wars
is oversaturated at this point I mean
you know you know so many damn sp sp
Star Wars shows movies video games I
mean don't get me wrong that Star Wars
Outlaws look pretty damn good but I mean
that's
fine you know you think about Indiana
Jones we haven't seen a lot of Indiana
Jones games I think theal Xbox you know
if they do an Indiana Jones really good
uh that might be it you know let me get
these super chats get us up out of here
D yep we got a $2 Super Chat from Adidas
a $5 Super Chat one more take we GNA
take D and send you kids through the
Wednesdays man you guys are rude $2
Super Chat t uh THX IGN and Spider-Man 2
review at eight PS Fanboys
quiet that is kind of funny $5 Super
Chat from Iron Mike 44 gaming
Insomniac made a met meta game after
meta game until they got Spider-Man IP
and followed uh the PS2 Spiderman
formula Wolverine could be M though you
you're right we don't know how
Wolverine's going to turn out I think
it's Insomniac man I think it's going to
be quality just just me
personally uh hopefully we got a member
chat from uh SIU prod X The Flash would
be the best lwh hanging fruit his story
arc and SSD use it would put in
work I actually like that last Flash
movie even though it didn't do well yeah
I just didn't like the ending but we
won't go into that yeah the ending t uh
THX Spider-Man meta 87 miles meta 83 mid
at best that that that that's a valid
credis I actually think miles is better
than the original Spider-Man me too uh
$2 Super Chat from smooth uh smooth
movie uh does Starfield get a game of
the year nomination uh I believe it will
I truly believe it will
yeah the $2 t uh THX 11138 nothing is
saying PS needs a shooter to compete see
that wasn't the conversation I've always
said from the start that PlayStation
needs to compete more and when it comes
to singleplayer games I mean multipler
I've always said that like in terms of C
thieves Shooters in general I've said
that they need to be more diverse
because I don't I don't think that
they're as diverse as as Microsoft and I
think that you know them cutting back on
Studios has made them less
diverse then we got a $2 per shot from
th uh th
x138 worst superhero game Superman 64 I
never played it but I saw it it looked
terrible then we got $5 from Corey
Tidwell spending 200 million on one and
done ain't worth it Sony's making profit
from Spider-Man controllers and console
face playes Microsoft could do that too
they already they already sell a bunch
of controllers and stuff uh then we got
$2 from Victor alisin well said dirt
XBox doesn't need need a superhero
game look at the end of the day you know
me and dirt we going we going to
disagree with stuff but there's nothing
but love man I it's all man when it
comes to D I know he wants best for the
Xbox ecosystem of course it's just we
might have different opinions on how it
goes through but D tell people where
they at while we uh close out of here
man all right man um check out my
channel listen man I my um my Starfield
not Starfield my ABK receipts video did
extremely well um check it out let me um
put my channel in the chat yeah did
pretty well man a lot of people I was I
was holding on to those receipts for a
long time hey what's up Jay Rock how you
doing I was holding on to those receipts
for a long time man it was great that I
was able to actually show those receipts
I had but yeah um that's about it man um
I put my link in the chat doing the dark
man show tomorrow having a good time
with that we're going to talk about some
of the things you talk about today we
going to talk about Starfield winning
September mpds even though it was in
Game Pass and some of the games it
actually beat it's kind of unbelievable
man you know me add talked about it but
yeah that's about it
y'all yeah so you know I appreciate
everyone coming through here you catch
me on YouTube gaming adct putting up
content pretty much every day uh got got
a video up right now definitely go check
that out uh I'm going to actually do
something different man I'm gonna send
you guys over to Boomstick gaming uh
definitely go there tell them addict and
dirt since you say the addict show sent
you guys you know I appreciate every for
coming through we're going to go and
close this out I'll see you next week
man tomorrow next week Spider-Man will
be up for the masses so we'll talk about
that but I appreciate every come through
and without further Ado I don't know why
I thought I was making a video you guys
have a good day what you about to do the
spin with the chair yeah yeah uh I'm
still thinking